mind your decisions i'm preshtalwalkar
a circular sector can be folded into the
shape of a three-dimensional cone by
joining its two radii together
the exact size of the cone will depend
on the size of the circular sector
let's unroll this cone back into a
circular sector
suppose that we have a fixed radius of
this circular sector and we just vary
the central angle of this circular
sector
what will happen to the cone
naturally the cone will change in size
it will go from tall and narrow to very
long and wide until it flattens into a
circle
each of these circular sectors
corresponds to a different size of the
cone
the question will be the following
if we have a circular sector whose
radius is equal to one and central angle
is equal to theta
what is the maximum volume of the cone
that's possible
part two
solve for theta when the cone's volume
is a maximum i thank joe for the
suggestion
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try and when you're ready
keep watching to learn how to solve this
problem
[Music]
the dimensions of the circular sector
will determine the size of the cone
the radius of the circular sector will
be equal to the slant height of the cone
since the radius is equal to 1 the slant
height is equal to 1.
we then have the arc length of the
circular sector will be equal to the
circumference of the base of the cone
the size of the arc length is equal to
its radius multiplied by the central
angle in this case we have 1 multiplied
by theta which will be equal to theta
therefore the circumference of the base
of the cone will also be equal to theta
now focus on just the cone
we'll label the radius of the base as r
and the height of the cone as h
we have a right triangle form between
the radius the height and the slant
height
we can thus use the gogu theorem to
determine that r squared plus h squared
is equal to one squared
we then solve this equation for r
squared
from here we will go to the formula for
the volume of a cone it will be equal to
1 3 pi r squared h
since we know what r squared is equal to
we'll substitute that into the formula
and then we'll simplify
we thus have a formula for the volume in
terms of just one variable h
we'll thus take the first derivative
with respect to h and we'll set it equal
to zero to solve for the maximum volume
we'll solve this equation very easily to
get that h is equal to one divided by
the square root of 3.
just for fun we can double check that
this is a local maximum
we then substitute the value for h into
the volume formula and we get the
maximum volume is equal to 2 pi divided
by 9 times the square root of 3.
from here we need to calculate the
central angle theta which gives us
maximum volume
to do that we'll solve for the radius
using this formula we'll solve for r and
then we'll substitute in for h
we get that r is equal to the square
root of two over three
then we consider the circumference of
the base of the cone
the circumference is equal to theta and
it's also equal to two pi r we
substitute in for r and we thus have the
value of theta in radians
we multiply this equation by 180 over pi
to get the answer in degrees and that's
approximately equal to 293 293.9 degrees
and that's our answer
this is a fun optimization problem and
the answer works out very nicely
thanks for making mind your decisions
one of the best channels on youtube as
always thanks for watching and thanks
for your support
[Music]